welcome to another episode of don't get
fork my name is Ryan I'm the club
manager here and this show is about
showing puzzles that all involve Forks
we have contestants come up a lot of
employees and club members will come up
and they'll look at a puzzle and try to
figure out how the best way to not get
forked and just so there's no confusion
about what a fork is a fork is one one
piece attacks two other pieces any piece
can fork so all of our puzzles are
supplied by international master Eric
Rosen so thank you very much for that
and let's go to the board one us we're
on welcome back to the next round of
don't get forked with us Alex patina
hello Alex tell the YouTube audience
what you're doing now nope all right so
in three seconds you're gonna turn
around and you're gonna see a position
on the board where it's blacks turn to
move you just said three extra I'll I'll
call up the 300 black Stern to move you
take the best move on the board that
involves not getting forked why to move
black to move get four okay black to
move but don't give four three two one
go Blackman who don't get forked all
right so it's not a whole lot pieces
this one should be relatively easy yeah
of course
don't address what's going on before
make the best move don't get forth I'm
gonna need you to move the piece with
your finger bone all right and you have
ten seconds
[Music]
seven alright that is the correct answer
good job Alex yeah I didn't get forked
when I have a fork I should get a spoon
cuz I didn't get forked all right Alex
Olga explain to me why you think King g7
or G our f7 is a bad move because you
can get forked you can't get for it so
let's let's go to f7 real quick if you
notice that the rook is on a light
square the King is on a light square the
knight is also on a light square and
it's got moved to a dark square for King
these two pieces all right now if we go
back King h7 again light square light
squared light square the night comes
here and you get four of course yeah
exactly
all right thank you very much Cheers
all right thanks for joining us on don't
get forked please like share and
subscribe to all our videos and if you
have any good fork puzzles please send
them to info at st. Louis chess club org
thanks